nehmen sie einfach die besten
bock geht ihnen präsentiert von fluor
punkt ch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
herr guttenberg
andré hoffmann und jörg buschmann
zwei der reichsten schweizer
seit 125 jahren ist ihre familie in
besitz von roche dem weltgrößten
pharmakonzern
ein zeichen setzen
ein wuchtiges zeichen
mächtig und dominant
die roche führen wir beherrschen die
skyline von basel
die höchsten gebäude der schweiz 205 und
178 meter hoch
[Musik]
sie haben das münster als wahrzeichen
der stadt abgelöst
roche erzielte im letzten jahr rund 60
milliarden franken umsatz und einen
gewinn von 15 milliarden franken
[Musik]
entscheidend ist dass wir wissen was gut
für die firma ist und was gut für die
firma ist es letztlich auch gut für die
familie und nicht das gegenteil nicht
was gute termin ist gut für die firma
hat sondern was gut für die
finanzinstitute die familie selbst
gepumpt
der basler konzern beschäftigt 100
tausend angestellte in über 100 ländern
auch unternehmen wie die roche ist nicht
an der börse kotiert wir müssen auch
natürlich die kurzfristigen erwartungen
befriedigen
börsenwert von roche diesen sommer
320 milliarden franken das wertvollste
unternehmen der schweiz im besitz einer
basler familie
[Musik]
andré hoffmann ist urenkel des
firmengründers
jörg buschmann vertritt die fünfte
generation und den familienzweig der
riss der weltkonzern bestimmt das leben
der roche erben
als garten abend dessen gegen haben wir
es merken wir ein stück von roche werden
vom tisch dass man darüber gesprochen
die beiden vertreten die familie im
verwaltungsrat des konzerns
bringt das standlicht
empfiehlt das privileg der für die
verantwortung übertragen
also wie eine familie schmuckstück
projekt auch eine familie fest und und
kennen wohl die nächste generation
wieder gerne es ist nicht nur ein
privileg es ist auch eine aufgabe
und die nehmen wir ernst
sind angekommen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
er muss es richten für die familie und
für die aktionäre roche chef severin
schwan der bestbezahlte manager der
schweiz jeden tag verdiente rund 40000
franken
mitte juli geht es aber um andere zahlen
der konzernchef präsentiert heute das
halbjahresergebnis wie immer bei gutem
wetter kommt er mit dem elektrovelo
der gemüse eigentlich nur die natur der
freiheit wo es schon sehr früh losgeht
wenn es ruhig ist und
also es ist eigentlich es ist eigentlich
entspannung bevor es dann so richtig
losgeht
also auf geht's
der ganze tag ist minuziös geplant
analysten und journalisten wollen vom
ceo wissen wie sich roche in der
pandemie schlägt
erstmals darf ein fernsehteam severin
schwan begleiten aber nicht überall hin
sein büro ist tabu wie auch sein
privatleben
der erste termin
telefonkonferenz mit den wichtigsten
internationalen finanzmedien wall street
journal reuters financial times im
hintergrund der online show die
mediensprecher
jedes quartal muss er liefern seine
aussagen können den aktienkurs
beeinflussen und so milliarden an
börsenwert vernichten oder generieren
sie sind familien und namen haben sie
weniger druck ich glaube wir haben das
beste von beiden welten auf der einen
seite haben wir natürlich den druck der
kapitalmärkte und müssen uns den fragen
stellen und auf der anderen seite
haben wir aber das privileg das man
wirklich
sehr langfristig denken können und auch
mal entscheidungen treffen die sich erst
in fünf oder in zehn oder vielleicht
sogar aus den 15 oder 20 jahren
auszahlen es folgen tv interviews mit
cnbc und blumberg alles muss stimmen das
ding noch ein bisschen höher als es muss
höher
der umsatz mit medikamenten ist um drei
prozent gesunken
doch die korona pandemie interessiert
deutlich mehr
action software as a result of it will
be in the future for testing and is
ja es waren die erwarteten fragen man
nimmt das nächste
vier minuten
geht es ja wirklich gesagt
wir haben insgesamt
gute ergebnisse
geliefert
die strategie auch im gespräch mit
schweizer medien positives hervorheben
negatives relativieren etwa dass roche
wegen patentabläufen bei den
krebsmedikamenten seit jahren milliarden
an umsatz verliert
umsatz noch einmal zurückgegangen mit
welchen verlusten rechnen sie daran den
nächsten jahr wir gehen jetzt davon aus
dass diese auswirkungen bereits im
zweiten halbjahr deutlich abnehmen
werden der entscheidende punkt ist
wirklich der erfolg von den neuen
produkten und wir können diese ausfälle
der älteren produkte durch diese neuen
produkte kompensieren der 54 jährige
tiroler kam direkt nach dem studium zu
roche und ist mittlerweile auch
schweizer
ja mein ganzes berufsleben ist geprägt
von der roche und in dem sinn bin ich
natürlich schon teil der roche familie
aber man darf seine eigene rolle dann
eine zu überschätzen die roche gibt es
schon seit 125 jahren und wird von einer
generation zur nächsten getragen
roche vor 125 jahren hier im kleinbasel
gestartet mit einer klaren strategie
medikamente industriell fertigen diese
mit viel marketing verkaufen und schnell
international expandieren
über all die jahre hat roche zudem nie
fusioniert ist immer eigenständig
geblieben ganz im sinne der familie
das firmenarchiv dokumentiert jedes
detail
aufbewahrt werden auch spezielle objekte
im zusammenhang mit erfolgreichen
produkten
[Musik]
oder die ungewöhnliche sponsoring
anfrage eines fußballklubs
um 7 von cristiano ronaldo und david
beckham ich habe mich immer gewundert
herr schwan hat sich nie dafür
interessiert
es kam mir sofort den sache ich diese
sprung signalfarben beruhigt mich dass
er sich nicht unter zu tragen
am anfang von roche steht das
desinfektionsmittel euro
mit vitaminen wird das unternehmen ab
der 1930 er jahren weltweit groß
valium heißt der nächste kassenschlager
das beruhigungsmittel mit dem ruf einer
gesellschafts droge ist ab 1968 über ein
jahrzehnt das meistverkaufte medikament
der welt
viele andere produkte erlangen große
bekanntheit die wundsalbe bepanthen oder
pantene zur haarpflege
roche hat die meisten aber längst
abgestoßen und verkauft nur noch
rezeptpflichtige und vor allem
margenträchtigere medikamente wie das
schlafmittel dormicum mariam gegen
malaria oder das grippemittel tamiflu
dessen wirkung bis heute umstritten ist
die bestseller der letzten jahre waren
die drei krebsmittel herceptin avastin
und mabthera ihre patente sind nun aber
abgelaufen am meisten in die kasse spült
heute das multiple sklerose medikament
rebif dieses jahr rund fünf milliarden
franken 8 prozent des konzernumsatzes
gedruckt wurde sie sehen also das war
sehr übersichtlich und auf eine art und
weise natürlich auch transparent
rausholte wobei nicht sehr viel drin
gestanden ist nicht es gab aber eine
bilanz und einer volkszählung man das
macht und
die firma hat mit einem kleinen gewinn
aufgeschnitten das verwaltungshandeln
und
dieses natürlich in jeden jeden das ist
das legendäre bildes gering das
hochzeitsfoto von tritt unter tel
hoffmann la roche
[Musik]
fritz hoffmann-la roche gründet die
firma 1896 sohn emanuel folgt ihm stirbt
aber früh seine frau meier stählin
heirate den dirigenten paul sacher in
den nachfolgenden generationen nimmt die
familie nur noch im verwaltungsrat
einsitz
durch heirat von vera hoffmann mit jakob
bildet sich der familienzweig er besteht
in der vierten generation aus fünf
geschwistern da nur zwei
geschwisterkinder haben schrumpft die
fünfte generation der es auch nur vier
mitglieder
bei den hoffmanns hat glück vier kinder
diese wiederum haben 82
mitglieder des hoffmann zweigs sterben
früh
mittlerweile sind kinder der sechsten
generation zur welt gekommen
insgesamt ist die anzahl erben aber
immer noch relativ klein mit ein grund
warum rasch noch in familienhand ist
ein anderer grund 15 mitglieder sind in
einem familientour vereint um mit einer
stimme zu sprechen
vertreter des familien tools im
verwaltungsrat sind andre hoffmann und
jörg buschmann
sie sind ja in einem pool organisiert
wie funktioniert das also wie spricht
man sich da also wie der pool selber
funktioniert wollen wir nicht unbedingt
veröffentlichen hab ja wir treffen uns
ja wir reden ja wir sind die selbe
meinung es ist natürlich etwas da
spontan kommt man muss daran arbeiten
man muss immer wieder diesen kontakt
aufsuchen verschiedenen jedes interesse
in der inderin aktionärsgruppe zu zu
verstehen und zu befriedigen also wir
haben eine ortsgruppe sondern sagen ja
[Gelächter]
gegen aussen treten ausschließlich diese
beiden auf wenn auch widerwillig und
selten
zum 125 jahr jubiläum ihres konzerns
machen sie eine ausnahme und geben eine
medienkonferenz
vorgängig werden sie vom medienteam
geprüft
36 journalisten die sich angemeldet
haben
es ist quasi die gesamte abdeckung
schweiz in deutschland
war sie ihre nachfolger so er ist von
einer fünften generation schon da hat
die ablösung stunden schaut gefunden und
und wie sehen sie das sowie plan sieht
auch meine normale antworten so zu sagen
dass mein grossvater zurückgezogen ich
sowas 90 jahre alt waren und ich habe
noch mindestens 30 helfern das
auch die frage nach momenten in der
rockgeschichte sei es so sei es andere
kritische momente in der geschichte
wieder ihre position des business
wahrgenommen haben auch mit dem vitamin
karte zum beispiel große gewinne große
morgen ein hoher lohn von severin und so
weiter das sind klassiker wie hattest du
ja
die probleme und skandale von roche zb
die seveso katastrophe von 1976
bei der roche tochter im italienischen
seveso tritt dioxin aus hunderte
menschen vor allem kinder erleiden
hautverletzungen
80.000 tiere sterben
anstatt die bevölkerung schnell zu
warnen vertuscht roche zuerst den unfall
und spielt ihn danach herunter
ein anderer skandal dass vitamin karte
der baseler roche konzern ist in den usa
gehörig an die kasse gekommen er zahlt
in einem vergleich mit dem
amerikanischen
justizdepartement eine rekordbuße von
750 millionen franken der basler konzern
wurde beschuldigt zusammen mit anderen
vitamin herstellern zwischen 1990 und 99
preisabsprachen vorgenommen zu haben die
europäische union hat den basler
pharmakonzern mit einer rekordbuße
bestraft nach der kartellbehörde
präsentieren jetzt auch private kläger
die als firmenkunden geschädigt worden
sind die rechnung für das unsaubere
vitamin geschäft
[Musik]
herr hoffmann machen sie das gerne
solche auftritte also mein herz kopf dem
moment ich mache mir auch sorgen weil
sie heute von den medien sehen und die
medien tieren gefährlich aber es ist ein
unglaublich ein hebeleffekt wenn wir
dieses
super
die hauptbotschaft für die medien ist
klar die besitzerfamilie und roche das
gehört zusammen
nachzulesen auch in der neuen historie
die der konzern für das jubiläum in
auftrag gegeben hat
historisch ist auch die medienkonferenz
zum ersten mal treten die beiden erben
gemeinsam auf
einen wunderschönen guten morgen ich
geheißen sie sehr herzlich willkommen
andré wenn du diese acht kilo bücher
hier so siehst was bedeutet das für dich
also wenn ich diese bücher sehen sind
bin ich natürlich sehr aufgeregt ich
finde dass man so eine eine
überschwemmung von sports die und die
kommt ja also ich kann nur dieses gefühl
von stolz eigentlichen zu streichen
diese firma existiert nicht um geld zu
machen diese firma existierenden
patienten zu helfen und es geht um die
sache und es wird um die sache fällt aus
dem zentrum es geht nicht um den
einzelnen in der familie
wie erwartet werden auch die skandale
der vergangenheit zum thema
das vitamin kartell das war nicht unsere
unsere unsere schönste stunde ich war da
wirklich noch ein kind aber ich erinnere
mich daran wie das ein thema am esstisch
zu hause wie man sich als familie
geschämt hat dafür dass so etwas hier
unsere unternehmung passieren konnte und
wie unser überzeugt so wird daraus
hervorgegangen sind dass wir dafür
sorgen wollen dass so etwas nicht mehr
vorkommen darf
nach über zwei stunden rede und antwort
zeigen sich die roche erben zufrieden
sie konnten ihre botschaft anbringen
dass die familie den konzern überhaupt
kontrollieren kann verdankt sie einer
altmodischen kapitalstruktur
[Musik]
der konzern hat zwei arten von
anteilsscheinen mit unterschiedlichen
rechten
die besitzer von genussscheinen erhalten
zwar eine dividende sie haben aber kein
stimmrecht an der generalversammlung
die besitzer von inhaberaktien hingegen
erhalten eine dividende
und sie können über die firma bestimmen
darum sind die genussscheine obwohl es
viermal mehr gibt nicht relevant für die
kontrolle des konzerns
entscheidend sind die inhaberaktien
45 prozent sind im besitz des aktionärs
puls der familien bury hoffmann
5,1 prozent gehören maja oeri die den
pool verlassen hat aber in der regel mit
der familie stimmt so können die roche
erben den konzern kontrollieren
33,3 prozent gehören der basler
konkurrentin novartis
der rest der inhaberaktien ist im
sogenannten streubesitz
jetzt hat novartis 33 prozent stört sie
das oder wie ist das generieren sie das
einfach
ignorieren ist nie eine gute lösung aber
ich denke nicht so ich wecken ich hoffe
in der nacht um darüber zu denken ist
das gar kein thema
wir sind gute nachbarn in der stadt
basel ist hat basels uns alle wichtig
novartis ebenfalls einer der grössten
pharmakonzerne der welt der damalige
chef daniel vasella macht mehrfach
avancen für eine fusion die roche
familie will aber nichts davon wissen
daniel vasella blitzt ab
gleich ergeht es zuvor martin ebner der
financier kauft um die jahrtausendwende
20 prozent der roche aktien und fördert
so einen verwaltungsratssitz und die
schaffung einer einheitsaktie auch er
beisst auf granit
der roche generalversammlung macht andré
hoffmann schon damals familien vertreter
klar wer das sagen hat
ihre dienste schlussfolgerung gekommen
dass er in unserer gewalt ums rad ist
sehr viel bringen könnte und haben das
auch entsprechend kommuniziert
die verwaltung ihre familie kritisiert
hat aber es kann wie ich glaube man kann
sagen dass ich sehr viel geholfen martin
ebner gibt auf und verkauft seine aktien
an novartis
die roche erben kontrollieren den
konzern aber nicht nur über die
generalversammlung sondern auch über
ihre beiden vertreter im verwaltungsrat
[Musik]
ich präsidiere das entschädigungs
komitee und das komitee für
nachhaltigkeit und
wir nach ein teil des präsidentielle
ausschuss und da versuchen wir eine
direkte rolle zu nehmen aber wir sind
ganz klar weiß and non executive der
unsere rolle ist nicht zu bestimmen was
die firma macht und rolle ich zu sehr
versichern das was sie macht im
richtigen sinne macht
sechsmal pro jahr trifft sich der 12
köpfige verwaltungsrat meist in basel
christoph franz der ehemalige swiss und
lufthansa chef ist
verwaltungsratspräsident
im gremium sitzen wirtschaftsgrößen wie
nestlé präsident paul bulcke swiss life
chef patrick frost oder beraterin
claudia süssmuth tochter der ex
bundestagspräsidentin rita süßmuth und
die beiden familien vertreter ich glaube
die familie hat primär das interesse bei
führungsfunktionen mit involviert zu
sein so will ich mal sagen also da geht
es sehr stark natürlich um die frage
verwaltungsratsmitglieder insbesondere
verwaltungsratspräsident
geht um die frage wer ist der ceo dieses
unternehmens und sicherlich auch bei der
ein oder anderen
schlüsselposition in der
geschäftsleitung
zum verwaltungsrat gehört auch severin
schwan andré hoffmann ist vizepräsident
und seit 25 jahren dabei jörg buschmann
seit gut einem jahr
[Musik]
jörg buschmann vertritt der
familienzweig der
37 jährige ist sohn von sabine r die
seit der heirat diesmal heißt
bis 2018 hat der promovierte chemiker
fünf jahre bei roche geforscht danach
wegen seines verwaltungsrats mandates
aufgebot
heute besucht er einen ehemaligen
kollegen
[Musik]
meiner doch kostet sie zwei tage firma
gesagt hat sie eigentlich nicht nein
sagen hört schon mal hört noch ein
regler biskup macht heute das schicksal
berichten oder so ich dir
schritte schon fraser
sofort wieder
einmal da sind sogar noch die
schließlich damit um mit merkel wenden
telefon
die maschine zur synthese photonik und
unkreativ das bedeutet im grunde kurze
dna sequenzen das heißt es sicher beats
levy eine besonders hohe gewinne druck
groß ist kann doch noch mal die
schließlich an denn im grunde überall
dort es ohne ausgang und so wird denn
die verschiedenen ganze wo sie druck
sehen werdet denn genauso wie es nötig
ist in die einzelnen reaktions quaas in
puncto
jetzt sowie dann das ist so behaftet ist
ja es ist schon gegangen um meine filme
geschafft und mehr oder weniger
attraktiv macht das ist sowieso nie
gemacht und jetzt würde sie sogar wieder
meister bordeaux und sogleich muss ich
wiederhole
nein ich glaube eigentlich ist es
wirklich einfach
qualitätsdefizite und letztlich im
prinzip toni genauso drin aufgang
geschickten forscher
und da ist was ich sage
das ist funktioniert schon mal überhaupt
[Musik]
dass sie das jetzt nicht so ungeschickt
rotkreuz der andere große standort von
roche in der schweiz
rund 3000 leute arbeiten hier für die
diagnostiksparte
sie ist die alte liebe von severin
schwan bevor er konzernchef wurde hat er
die sparte geleitet diese erlebt gegen
korona einen großen aufschwung
[Gelächter]
roche entwickelt hier diagnosegeräte
schon kurz nach ausbruch der pandemie
konnten sie corona pcr tests machen
dafür gab es lob von donald trump und
anderen regierungschefs
diese riefen severin schwan sogar
persönlich an
irgendwann
ruft und sie überlegen sich nehmen sie
das jetzt ab und dann haben sie die
effektiv am mobiltelefon
ein regierungschef am apparat und
überlegen sie ist es jetzt wirklich her
oder tut er das so und
es war aber tatsächlich die
regierungschefs und das zeigt einfach
wie groß der druck war also da hatte die
person vielleicht am nächsten tag
medienkonferenz und wollte noch ein
update bekommen
und und hat danone irgendwie jetzt da
die üblichen wege einzuschlagen einfach
sagt jetzt so viel direkter
dies wird diagnosegeräte stehen in
labors und spitälern sie analysieren
spuck proben oder nase rachenabstriche
vollautomatisch in 90 minuten
für den corona pcr test musste roche nur
das testmaterial neu entwickeln die
schnellsten geräte schaffen 3000 tests
pro tag darum spielen sie bei der
bekämpfung der pandemie eine große rolle
diagnostik sowie das stiefkind
jetzt sind sie plötzlich ist es da vista
das ist mega cool wie früher nach extra
diagnostik diagnostik ist ganz wichtig
um der ärzte
neben dem image gewinn kurbelt die
pandemie den umsatz an wohl auch
langfristig den roche hat nun viele
maschinen verkauft stehen diese einmal
in einem labor oder spital ist es
einfacher auch mit anderen tests und
reagenzien geld zu verdienen
es gibt
für infektionskrankheiten oder auch für
krebskrankheiten die auf diesen systemen
laufen und unsere chance ist dass wir
jetzt wir nennen das das menü also die
anzahl der verschiedenen tests auf
diesen instrumenten erweitern und damit
natürlich auch noch am besten beitrag
für für das gesundheitssystem liefern
können und gleichzeitig unsere
marktposition und unser geschäft
ausgestellt
in rotkreuz werden die diagnose
maschinen auch zusammengebaut jede
einzeln von hand
nach ausbruch der pandemie lief die
produktion auf hochtouren viele
mitarbeitende mussten monatelang auch
samstags arbeiten
auch der konzernchef machte überstunden
mehr als für ihn übrig
hin und wieder gibt es probleme
denkt man beim einschlafen die denkbaren
aber meine frühe aufwacht also ich ich
bin eine die personen die die zumindest
behaupten dass sie völlig abschalten
können
sie hätte gern die fähigkeit aber exakt
hobbys
der umsatz der diagnostik sparte zu der
auch die selbsttests gehören explodierte
wegen der pandemie
das kompensierte den einbruch bei den
medikamenten
was und jetzt ja jetzt kommen noch
sitzungen für laufende forschungs und
entwicklungsprojekte da geht's um die
längerfristige zukunft und daher können
sie dabei sein aber in zehn jahren
treffen uns da wieder und dann schauen
wir was man von markt gebracht haben
das ziel von severin schwan die nummer 1
bleiben
[Applaus]
das tango museum image-pflege am
standort basel
roche hat es vor 25 jahren der stadt
geschenkt
dieses engagement ist ganz im sinne der
familie danke lieber ein freund von
meyer sache hoffmann
er hat zum beispiel den achtzigsten
geburtstag von großmutter hatte ein
feuerwerk gemacht und er hat also auf
holzrahmen
maja hat er viele kleine rakete angemalt
und dann dürfte das anfühlen ich war
damals was 18 19 ich war sehr aufgeregt
ich durch darum gehen eine
explodieren alles ausgelöst
roche finanziert auch den betrieb des
museums und investiert in den erhalt der
kunst im staat eli werden werke von
tango die aus aller welt wieder in gang
gebracht
dieses lag mehrere jahre in einem keller
in paris
die woche noch wegen
zersetzung
somit
eine wurden mit suppe geschrieben und
das ist etwas super jahren
das waren briefe geschrieben hatte ich
beantrage
familie sind viele sammler umdrehen die
winzigen
kohlenstoff ich habe einen weinkeller
also ist nicht für die ewigkeit ja das
ist eigentlich gemeint für konsum
[Applaus]
kunst und kultur nicht nur vom konzern
gefördert sondern auch von der familie
selbst die roche erben gehören zu den
größten mit zähnen der schweiz sie
können es sich leisten
mit einem vermögen von rund 35
milliarden franken sind die hoffmann und
oeri es die zwei dreiste familie der
schweiz hinter jener von ikea gründer
ingvar kamprad
vom reichtum der roche erben profitiert
die stadt basel im großen stil
vor allem die oris die immer noch in
basel leben betätigen sich hier als mit
zähnen
[Musik]
sie haben viele museen finanziert und
sammlungen gespendet
unterstützen die musikakademie den zoo
eine kirche die universität oder
online-medien sie betreiben einen jazz
campus eine alzheimer tagesstätte und
günstige wohnungen überall in der stadt
dazu kommen viele andere engagement kurz
die roche erben prägen basel bis heute
mit geschätzt einer milliarde franken
[Musik]
maja oeri etwa spendet 50 millionen an
den neubau des kunstmuseums aber nur
unter der bedingung dass auch die stadt
50 millionen beisteuert
im museum selber hängen bilder der
familie wie die weltberühmte brennende
giraffe von salvador dalí das zu emanuel
hoffmann stiftung gehört
[Musik]
die bilder der stiftung die nicht
ausgestellt sind werden im schaulager
aufbewahrt
bei dessen einweihung tritt marie
ausnahmsweise öffentlich auf
zu einem lagerhaus in dem die werke
unverpackt und richtig installiert
geladen sind die basler roche mit szene
sind verschrieben fotos von ihnen gibt
es praktisch keine interviews ebenfalls
nicht das gilt auch für sabine duschl
die mutter von jörg buschmann sie
spendet millionen für klassische musik
etwa für die musikakademie erst kürzlich
willigte sie ein das zumindest ihr name
sichtbar wird
[Musik]
dass man eben nicht sich selber immer im
vordergrund gerne sieht
und ich glaube ich weiß nicht wie das
für dich ist aber ich meine so eine
situation wird die jetzt ist auch für
mich nicht ganz einfach und nicht etwas
was ich in meinem alltag und gerne mache
und genauso wie das halt den anderen
mitgliedern der familie auch und deshalb
bleiben die hebel ein bisschen im hinzu
kommt die ausnahme der regel gg sie ist
durch die heirat mit andreas illi in den
roche klein gekommen mit dessen geld
finanziert sie den fc basel und bringt
ihn an die schweizer spitze legendär und
von einigen roche erben nicht goutiert
ihr auftritt beim gewinn des ersten
meistertitels 2002
bei den hunger
je höher die
aktie der wette eingelöst und party mit
der mannschaft
seit ihrem rücktritt beim fcb ist auch
sie kaum mehr in der medien und auch sie
hat eine interviewanfrage abgelegt
[Musik]
man gibt aber spricht nicht darüber so
eine basler redensart das mäzenatentum
erst möglich macht die dividende aktien
dürfen die erben nicht verkaufen wenn
sie die mehrheit an roche behalten wolle
aber dividende fließt reichlich roche
hat sie die letzten 34 jahre
ununterbrochen erhöht
allein dieses jahr erhielt die familie
729 millionen fragen
über 34 jahre addiert wurden gut 10
milliarden an dividenden ausgeschüttet
davon profitieren neben basel auch
andere orte
etwa in südfrankreich
1 56 meter hoher turm dominiert die
region der futuristische bau hat 150
millionen euro gekostet
das kunst und kulturzentrum ist das werk
von maja hoffmann ordensschwester sie
hat es im juni mit stararchitekt frank
gehry eingeweiht die roche erbin missal
schon länger auf
mit der umwandlung einer eisenbahn
werkstätte mit
eigenen hotels im städtchen und mit
einem van gogh museum die mäzenin stößt
bei der bevölkerung aber nicht nur auf
anklang
[Musik]
maja hoffmanns wirken in arles hängt mit
ihrer kindheit zusammen
sie wächst mit ihren geschwistern in der
camargue nähe von arles auf
vaterglück baut ihr 1954 eine
forschungsstation untersucht die
artenreiche vogelwelt und setzt sich für
die erhaltung der feuchtgebiete 1 in
dieser zeit gründet der naturschützer
mit anderen zusammen den wwf
gleichzeitig sitzt er im verwaltungsrat
von roche für ihn kein widerspruch
obschon
special eigentliche problem in der
richtigkeit glaube dass sie manager über
umwelt
verhalten vor ich glaube immer
gesagt dass wenn so etwas passiert sind
die er noch als korrigiert worden sind
die camargue ist heute großflächig
geschützt
der schutz der natur ist auch im elsass
ein thema in der petite camargue acht
kilometer von basel entfernt auch ein
feuchtgebiet nur viel kleiner als das
vorbild in südfrankreich
luc hoffmann hat hier während des
theologiestudiums in basel vögel
erforscht
sohn andré finanziert nun eine
professorenstelle an der universität
basel die hier eine forschungsstation
betreibt
für die nachhaltigkeit setzt andré
hoffmann fit zeit und geld ein das
fordert er auch von roche gibt keine
nachhaltigkeit ohne 1 1 diese symbiose
diese diese diese harmonie zwischen
natur und menschheit und wenn es keine
zukunft gibt dann gibt es auch keine
rossmann also ich glaube es ist einfach
eine sache der vernunft und das heißt
das wer geht der natur einen gewissen
frieden abkommen zahlen schauen müssen
dass wir bis jetzt noch nicht gemacht
haben aber die realität unterführung
sich ein bisschen anders als mein mann
sitzt hier und dreht sich die vögel an
dass das klingt dann gut aber in der
realität ist manchmal ein bisschen herz
so weiß nicht alles geht aber ich sage
es noch mal die idee ist nicht zu nur
über natur zu bringen denn dies zu reden
über soziales über übermenschliches über
ein nachhaltigkeits modell und
nachhaltigkeit ist auch erfolg zu haben
eine firma die kerngewinn macht kann
nicht nachhaltig sei allerdings der
gewinn ist sehr hoch mit rekordmarken
von über 30 prozent
hoffmann rechtfertigt dies etwa mit den
hohen forschungskosten
[Musik]
wir stehen jetzt im gang und sie gucken
jetzt gerade in die indy labor welt rein
kann mit den schritt vorgehen also wenn
ich sie
also das ist jetzt so wie der licht
stand sein wird ich weiß nicht
irgendwann im juni und sie sehen also
das labor wie lichtdurchflutet und wie
transparent ist wie weit man gucken kann
wie ist das eigentlich mit den
laboranten und laboranten müssen die
eintritt sorgen sie dafür dass
am vor standort im aargauischen
kaiseraugst steht ein modell im maßstab
eins zu eins severin schwan hat das
testlabor schon mehrmals besucht es soll
später zu hunderten in basel gebaut
werden
die
holzverkleidungen in den gängen das gibt
dem ganzen eine gewisse wohnlich gemacht
sie waren also wir haben auch ganz wenig
serien sich ersparen an die diskussion
wo sie sagten die ecken sind für mich
die schönsten räume
das wetter klar oder die luftig stand es
kann nicht sein dass ausgerechnet
allerdings stellt dann muss es im labor
und heute haben wir eben da das sind
jetzt diese diese labore drinnen diese
spezial sachen da bin ich aber wirklich
stolz jedes mal wenn ihnen das gebäude
gehen wird werden
die labors werden virtuell und auch real
aufgebaut um schon im vorfeld fehler
auszumerzen
und dazu gehört der schutz der umwelt
und auch im labor gibt es viele
möglichkeiten dass man mit nachhaltigen
materialien
wirkt ja fast ausschließlich mit
nachhaltigem anja einzige wo wir jetzt
passieren die grenzen gekommen sind wir
haben viel holz im labor oder das ist
relativ neu das gibt's ja wenn der
ganzen schweiz da muss man jetzt in lack
drauf machen der funktioniert und das
ist eine ganze nachhaltig
roche wird vom dow jones sustainability
index fast jährlich zum nachhaltigsten
pharmakonzern gekürt kritik gibt's
trotzdem
etwa wegen severin schwan sloane er
verdient jährlich rund 15 millionen
franken so viel wie kein anderer manager
in der schweiz
nachhaltig ihre lohn nachhaltig so viel
das auch nachvollziehen dass es der
diskussion gibt was meinen lohn angeht
ist natürlich vor allem wichtig dass
unabhängig der vergütungsausschuss vom
verwaltungsrat den
entscheidet aber letztlich
auch der das gleiche was ich mit meinen
eigenen leuten machen ich schaue mir die
leistungen
resultate stimmen das ist die
grundvoraussetzung für hohe löhne der
lohn von herr schwan das ist nicht
nachhaltig bei der mensch kann gar nicht
so viel verdienen sondern interessante
frage
was ist die haben
nachhaltigkeit heißt auch in talent
einem riesigen auch zu haben und wir
sind im wettbewerb mit anderen firmen
finden sollen talent von 3 kommt wir ein
internationaler maßstab das ist nicht
nur ein gesellschaftliches problem ist
etwas größer als fast also das heißt
wenn sie denn da logan ab sagt er ist
wohl der bi oder dann gesehen es ist
offiziell
ich glaube dass eine frau sieht das ja
schon dass ich auf unsere firma ist und
sie lohnen macht man doch keine
schlaflose nacht
ein anderer kritikpunkt die hohen
medikamentenpreise
ein arzt entdeckt per zufall dass das
krebsmittel avastin auch gegen
altersblindheit wirkt
roche bringt darauf los end ist auf den
markt das praktisch gleich ist außer
beim preis
einer spritze lucentis kostet 1800
franken
eine spritze avastin nur 40 franken und
das bei der nachgewiesen gleich guten
wirkung doch avastin darf offiziell
nicht eingesetzt werden denn roche hat
nur säntis für die behandlung von
altersblindheit absegnen lassen
die krankenkassen dürfen deshalb nur
lucentis vergüten dieses wird in europa
von novartis vertrieben
die italienische wettbewerbsbehörde
wollte sich das nicht bieten lassen und
verurteilte roche und novartis zu je 90
millionen euro
in frankreich haben roche und novartis
letztes jahr aus dem gleichen grund eine
buße von zusammen 4 144 millionen
erhalten beide bussen sind noch nicht
rechtskräftig und in der schweiz hat es
seit 2008 9 vorstöße in bundesbern
gegeben
gesundheitsminister albers musste schon
mehrfach stellung nehmen letztmals im
frühling
nun abermals viele passive
privat oder
seine produkte
es ist einfach ein fauler trick sind
zwei verschiedene medikamente die
unterschiedliche entwicklung genommen
haben unterschiedliche jeder sein
eigenes investment gehört hat und
entsprechend sind sie also
unterschiedliche medikamente auf dem
markt die zahlen wodurch verurteilt zu
einer buße von 90 millionen wie erklären
sie sich das
ja wir sind mit dem urteil zunächst
nicht einverstanden es gibt eine reihe
von ländern die das anders sehen ich
muss das zur kenntnis nehmen aber da der
entscheidende punkt ist dass die private
industrie ein anreiz hat in innovationen
der zukunft zu investieren damit sich so
wie in der vergangenheit das
gesundheitssystem ständig
weiterentwickelt und dann auch patienten
von solchen hervorragenden innovationen
wie los andes profitieren können also
hand aufs herz in diesem fall lucentis
aus den haben sie noch nie gedacht da
haben wir vielleicht ein fehler gemacht
ganz im gegenteil
[Musik]
den standort in basel baut roche seit
jahren mächtig aus
direkt neben den beiden bürotürmen
entsteht ein riesiges forschungszentrum
mit vier gebäuden das höchste ist 114
meter hoch
sie finden zukunft
größter airbus sind gerade wieder nach
hilfen architekturen geben müssen wieder
dafür architektonisches detail
aufmerksam
einmal die fenster ich finde diese
fenster unglaublich elegant hase in der
klarheit und in der chemie qualität und
wir haben alte gebäude aus den 30er
jahren der genau dieses gleiche element
hat mich
riesig spaß gemacht aber das tolle ist
bei der roche kann interessiert sogar
ausleben
roche investiert 1,2 milliarden franken
in das neue forschungszentrum das ist
mehr als für die beiden bürotürme
zusammen
1800 leute arbeiten hier künftig in
labors die severin schwan zuvor mit der
3d brille virtuell angeschaut hat
innovation irgendwann laufen die patente
von unseren medikamenten aus und dann
braucht man neue medikamente und die
wandern in zukunft aber in diesen
räumlichkeiten entstehen ob es mit notiz
finde ja wenn man immer am ball bleibt
wenn wir immer an der spitze steht
dann klappt's halt hin und wieder aber
sie haben schon recht es klappt nicht
immer
darum setzt roche stark auf übernahmen
allein seit der jahrtausendwende hat der
konzern 50 firmen gekauft für über 100
milliarden franken der größte deal
schien n tec 2009 für rund 50 milliarden
franken mit der us biotech firma wird
roche die nummer eins im lukrativen
krebs geschäft und mit der übernahme der
deutschen boehringer mannheim wird roche
weltweiter marktführer in der diagnostik
der
erfolg von roche hängt so stark von
übernommenen firmen und deren produkten
ab
99 prozent der innovation im
wissenschaftlichen bereich im
medizinischen bereich
passiert irgendwo außerhalb von der
roche und deshalb ist es ganz
entscheidend für uns diese innovation
die überall entsteht auf der ganzen welt
den akademischen institutionen in
anderen unternehmen dass wir die auch in
die rolle hinein bringen die kehrseite
der milliardenteuren übernahmen hohe
medikamentenpreise denn die kaufsummen
müssen wieder eingespielt werden
wie lange brauchen
ganz letztlich stationen
wartung um 15 uhr
im nächsten kampf sehr schön
[Musik]
die riesige investition in basel ist
ganz im sinn von jörg schmale und der
familie
basel und roche eine symbiose der
konzern kann praktisch ohne widerstand
türme bauen im gegenzug profitieren
stadt und bevölkerung von hohen
steuereinnahmen von 11.000 gut bezahlten
jobs und vom mäzenatentum
[Musik]
heckler basel ist sehr zentral für
unsere familie andere wie in basel
wirklich der wahrheit bezeichnet sich
als auslands basel ich glaub basel und
bass unterhalt ist showbiz wobei unsere
familien fragt was ihnen das du var ich
glaube das ist das lief die
understatement neue methode das
[Applaus]
biz druck zogen aber doch mit stolz auf
das managen dass man erreicht hätten
bescheidenheit und understatement was
für die erben gilt gilt nicht unbedingt
für roche der pharmariese hat sich ein
denkmal gesetzt
und der roche klein mittlerweile in
fünfter generation lässt keinen zweifel
daran dass er mit dem konzern basel noch
lange prägen wird
[Musik]
und liebt man hält
dort wurde ihnen präsentiert von fleurop
punkt ch